[Musique]
une sénatrice au volant d'un hélicoptère
ce simulateur de vol permet aux futurs
pilotes de s'exercer l'aérodrome de
toussus le noble était le premier à le
mettre à disposition pour la formation
tout ce qui sera pas possible en fait
durant le vol réel est bien ou ce qu'il
n'aura pas été vu comme par exemple des
météos très dégradé dans lesquels on ne
se met pas sur des vols réel on va
pouvoir confronter le pilote à ce type
de météo pour le jour le fameux au cas
où
eh bien il aura déjà vu sur simulateur
de façon très réaliste et sera du coup
comment se comporter les sénateurs ont
passé la matinée à visiter cet aérodrome
et ses technologies autre exemple unique
en france l'avion électrique d'une
autonomie d'une heure cet avion
électrique il a un avantage
extraordinaire c'est qu'il ne fait pas
de bruit
il est blanc pourquoi parce que c'est
l'avion de l'onu c'est l'avion de la
paix avec les riverains tellement il est
silencieux notre sujet a tous eu et de
réduire les nuisances
réduisez les nuisances sur
l'environnement et donc nous innovons
avec des start up qui vont générer de
nouvelles motorisations hybrides
électriques
l'avion électrique des nouveaux usages
et surtout un dialogue qui conte à
favoriser au niveau local au niveau
territorial entre les riverains et les
usagers
un sujet qui répond aux problématiques
actuelles des sénateurs l'intérêt est
évidemment à quelques jours d'entamer
les discussions sur la loi climat
énergie eh bien nous sommes là sur un
secteur d'activité qui est
l'aéronautique qui est aussi un secteur
d'activité primordial pour la france et
qui va être absolument exemplaire dans
la recherche d'économies d'énergie
d'économie des nuisances
le projet de loi énergie climat a été
adoptée à l'assemblée nationale en
première lecture le même jour le texte
arrivera en discussion au sénat le 16
juillet